welcome back one california restaurant
owner's rage against the lockdowns
went viral this week take a look
mayor garcetti and gavin newsom is
responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
joining me now is the owner of pineapple
hill saloon and grill in sherman oaks
california
angela marsden angela thank you so much
for being with us but most of all for
that incredible video i've got to tell
you
i've never watched anything that's
related to a story in the news that had
had a greater emotional impact on me
than watching your video um
for those who haven't seen it just tell
us your story
um well i mean the day that i did that
video
um basically they started the lockdown
uh well they closed outdoor dining two
days before thanksgiving
without any notice so our last night was
the night before thanksgiving
and i had to tell my staff that i would
like to stay open for takeout but
i lose so much money doing it that if i
did that i may not be able to
ever reopen again so i had to shut down
that friday i was coming in to give last
paychecks
and we had taken what food would go bad
and put it in grocery bags for the staff
i also had decided ironically you know
the week before that
i was not going to be afraid and i was
going to start speaking out so i was
trying to
plan a protest and
i came in to my parking lot and
there was my you know when i come in the
back
it was very surreal because or shot you
know shocking
um i have my patio that i have spent you
know i'm living off loan money
sitting there shuttered and then right
there in the same parking lot within 20
steps
was um the same example right now by the
way
yeah yeah the same exact setup for
a movie um crew to eat lunch and stuff a
catering truck and uh
you know a tent for 200 people it seemed
like to me i don't know
and i was in shock and i i went in
into my restaurant and was like trying
to stay focused to get
things together and i just broke down
crying and then i got angry and i said
i have to tell the truth i mean yes i
think as business owners
we're afraid to say anything because
we're afraid to be taken like we don't
care about people if we stay open or
we're just worried about us but
you know i have 10 people working for me
that i had to tell have
they have no job right before christmas
with no notice and
i just said to my friend who's there
i gotta film this i gotta let the world
see i got people have to know
the hypocrisy of what is going on and it
makes no sense
exactly none of it makes sense and the
other point is that you just like so
many small businesses
you've been responsible you put in the
investment
so that you could be open with outdoor
dining and do it in a safe manner you've
done
all the things that we would want people
to do and still they crush you
it's so enraging um angela i saw that
the mayor eric garcetti put out a
statement saying
oh his heart goes out to you but he's
still going to keep you shut down
um what's your response and what do you
want to say to him
you know i i mean to
what i want to say to him is that as
business owners we have done
everything you wanted and we will do
whatever it takes to keep our people
safe we know kobe's out there
but you're living in la la land
if you think the rest of us the middle
class and the lower middle class
can actually stay at home we are going
you know i have a single mom with a
child who can't pay her rent
i've got another another per new hire
because we actually got busy in october
with
the patio and it looked like things were
going to turn around who
is couch surfing because she no longer
has an apartment and her
unemployment has run out it is
ridiculous
and and as politicians or mayor of the
city it is your
job to look at risk assessment
and and to do you know the gentleman you
just had on brilliant can he talk to
mayor garcetti
because the decisions that are being
made
make no sense and you know beverly hills
their council voted to keep it pasadena
is open the sheriff is
you know what a wonderful sheriff to say
he wouldn't enforce it but
you know they're threatening to take
liquor license and health permits away
if we
defy it and open but what are we
supposed to do
how are we going to eat how are we gonna
keep a roof over our head like they're
not that
like you said you know the suicide rate
you know my this single mom with a child
who can't pay her rent
i said you know i'm going to do
everything i can to see if like i can
find you work and she's like angela all
i know how to do is bartend or wait
tables
and i said well what have you so
disgusting it's disgusting and
and and she's like well i did i did get
on some anti-depressants
she doesn't need pills she needs it
this is so outrageous honestly i've just
got to tell you thank you angela for
speaking up
i want to stay in touch with you because
you're r you're such a powerful voice
you you've joined you you're really
leading the resistance to all this we've
got to fight back against this because
their rules make no
sense they're ridiculous they're not
based on science
it is completely unacceptable and we
should not accept it
i'm so let's i'm sorry we've got to go
now angela but i just want to thank you
for what you're doing and let's stay in
touch and follow the campaign and we're
right behind you
thank you so much i really appreciate it
thank you